the kids are back to school and that
means it is time to get organized for
the upcoming year and no one is better
at that than our guest today she is the
owner of neat method professional
organizers it is melanie walker hi
oh thanks for having me it's so great to
be back you are the queen of need now
give us some tips as we get back to
school and we need to organize our life
and get those kids out the door so we're
talking about efficiency right and if
this this is a couple quick things i
could go for an hour you know on all
this stuff but put a basket for donate
in the kid's closet okay you know after
you hopefully you've cleaned out the
closet right that would be the first
thing you know get out get anything just
closed
out and out with the old and so i we we
labeled this one too small okay um and
so kids can kind of start editing on
their own as well they can be you put
stuff on put it in the basket it goes to
donate or sometimes they're
hand-me-downs that go to the next kit
okay so this is interesting you got
these hangers and i never knew this what
is so there do you know there's three
sizes of hangers so there's obviously
the adult size there's the baby size
there's also a kids size so this is a 14
inch hanger it's available on amazon
container store has them as well but so
when they start falling off the baby
hangers but they're the stuff's too big
you know they're too this stuff's too
small for big hanger they can go to a
medium sized hanger who knew
completely worth it okay now if you
don't have a mud room like a lot of
people you have this cool contraption so
backpacks come in kids dump their stuff
all over the place right and so
keeping stuff off the floor is one way
to stay really super neat so if you
don't really have a mud room or a set of
hooks somewhere this is a little s hook
and you can just put your on put your
backpacks and hang them on a rod in a
closet you know when you come in or if
you had a
rolling rack something like that so it
makes it look so neat well it just gets
them off the floor they have a place
where they all go yeah you know keeping
them efficient okay school supplies what
do we do with that just make an art
caddy uh make make a supply caddy pens
pencils glue all the things that they
need they can take it they can carry it
around the house because you know our
kids like to work
all over the house right sometimes
they're at the coffee table sometimes at
the end of their dining room table some
of these are in their room they can just
carry this around all their stuff is
there
now second this is the other thing take
the same art caddy make a
get ready bin like downstairs or
somewhere so kids don't have to run back
to their bathroom to get ready last
minute ponytail last minute sunscreen i
love that keep this in the kitchen or
right by the door where you're where
you're getting ready to leave i love
that right so and
tooth brushing everything you want to
get these kids
out the door efficiently now we only
have like 10 seconds left but let's talk
about masks really quick and sanitizing
so just make a basket for them you know
it's unfortunate that we have to have
this this basket but this one's labeled
ppe um and so it's all the things they
need grab and go and you're set yeah and
then let just lastly
get a parent action bin
you got it you know where so that's
where your all the papers go all the
projects yeah melanie you have the best
advice thank you so much for more
information neatmethod.com and las vegas
meet on instagram we will be right back